l'ukraine s'est le plus grand pays
agricole d'europe sur l'échiquier
mondial en agriculture c'est un joueur
de premier plan cinquième exportateur de
blé quatrième exportateur de maïs
premier quand les questions d'huile de
tournesol la fleur nationale du pays
mais alors que signifie l'agriculture en
temps de guerre je me suis entretenu
avec des producteurs agricoles qui se
trouve bien malgré eux au coeur du
conflit
[Musique]
des champs de blé transformée en champ
de tir alors que les russes poursuivent
leur évasion les traces de leur passage
sont bien visibles même la machinerie
agricole n'échappe pas à la folie des
hommes dans les zones occupées les
agriculteurs se retrouvent pris en étau
coût
[Musique]
serait lui du combat entre path to shine
co gère une ferme laitière de trois cent
cinquante vaches à 20km de kherson la
première ville ukrainienne capturé par
les russes
aujourd'hui toute la région est tombé
aux mains de l'occupant à la ferme le
quotidien a été complètement bouleversée
car
pour éviter de gaspiller le précieux
l'est l'équipe de 70 employés se met à
la transformation et improvise une
petite fromagerie les produits de la
ferme sont distribués gratuitement dans
les villages des alentours des
livraisons sont aussi organisés vers les
hôpitaux de la ville de carson
mais la ferme de 1500 hectares est
complètement isolés par les combats la
nourriture pour les animaux ne pourra
pas durer éternellement
sa cause cmaj à lucerne
kkl
alors que la saison des semis approche à
grands pas renflouer les réserves de
fourrage semble pour l'instant
impossible
ok maintenant chef le
général
de toute façon les semences qui devait
lui être livrés en mars ne sont jamais
arrivés
dans les régions où ont eu lieu les
combats tous lutte d'abord pour leur
survie
alex les sites ça qu'on voit ici lors de
jours meilleurs dans une vidéo
promotionnelle gère une énorme
entreprise agricole de 120 mille
hectares l'équivalent de deux fois et
demie l'île de montréal le volet
laitiers de l'entreprise compte
millevaches logé dans une étable parmi
les plus modernes d'ukraine
[Musique]
avec notre
du monde
il n'y a évidemment pas que la
production laitière qui est touché
[Musique]
l'ukraine est un géant de la production
céréalière et oléagineuses ses terres
noires sont parmi les plus fertiles du
monde mais la guerre mais aujourd'hui en
péril son rôle de grenier on estime que
la production pourrait chuter cette
année de 40 % au delà de la difficulté
d'accès aux champs pour des raisons de
sécurité la pénurie d'engrais est un
autre enjeu majeur selon cette
spécialiste du marché des grains mons
trio gagnant nuit 90% du blé ukrainien
c'est du blé d'automne donc il a déjà
été plantés mais au sortir de l'hiver il
faut appliquer des fertilisants si on ne
le fait pas on va perdre beaucoup de
rendement qui pas trop fio mais la
guerre ne fera pas toutes les fermes de
la même façon
le carburant hautement convoitée en
temps de guerre se fait aussi rare chez
andré passe tchenko qui craint de se
faire voler ses réserves
si la guerre rend très difficile
l'importation et le transport de
produits clés comme le carburant les
engrais et les semences le casse-tête
logistique ne s'arrête pas là les
ukrainiens ne peuvent plus exporter leur
gré car 95% des exportations se font via
les ports de la mer noire et de la mer
d'azov aujourd'hui bloquée oui sauf nous
avons environ six millions et demi de
tonnes de blé sourtout du blé meunier 15
millions de tonnes de maïs et beaucoup
tournesol qui pourrait être triturer
pour obtenir de l'huile et du tourteau
pour les animaux mais tout ça est coincé
dans des silos en ukraine parce qu'on ne
peut rien exporté expose
une très mauvaise nouvelle certes pour
l'ukraine mais aussi pour les pays qui
dépendent de ces denrées agricoles
70% du blé au liban par exemple provient
de l'ukraine mons la majorité de ce que
nous produisons nous l'exportons les
agriculteurs et craignent à nourrice
plus de 400 millions personnes dans le
monde dont votre hôte on ne mesure pas
encore toutes les conséquences de cette
guerre déjà le prix du blé a grimpé en
flèche
l'agriculteur néerlandais qui sera hôte
signera qui vit en ukraine et cultivent
la terre là bas depuis 20 ans il voit un
signal d'alarmé si on s'aime pas atteint
on sera confronté à une catastrophe bien
plus grande encore que la guerre qui
sévit en ce moment
à la demande de ses confrères
d'ukrainiens qui l'ont désigné comme
leur ambassadeur ce fermier fait la
tournée des médias et s'adresse aux
politiciens européens pour les
sensibiliser à l'urgence de régler le
conflit on ne peut pas se permettre de
rats la 16 en un sommet parce que sinon
on n'aura rien à récolter
et dans les pays d'afrique du nord et du
moyen-orient
il n'y aura pas assez de nourriture tout
foot
tous ces gens vont soit mourir de faim
ou se ruer vers l'europe
et alors le problème sera bien pire que
ce qu'on vit en ukraine
l'ukraine sortait d'une récolte record
en 2021 jamais ces chants n'avait été
aussi généreux ironiquement une partie
de sa population a aujourd'hui besoin d'
aide alimentaire
et les pays qui dépendent de l'ukraine
devront attendre
[Musique]
pour produire un maximum de nourriture
destinée à la population locale les
fermiers ukrainien sèmeront ce printemps
beaucoup moins de maïs et de tournesol
de culture qui sont plutôt destinées à
l'exportation elles seront remplacées
par du sarrasin du millet de l'orge des
poids des cultures qui arrivent plus
vite à maturité ils pourront rapidement
nourrir le peuple